so ist das viel zu schwer fällt wenn wir
haben eigentlich nur eingestellt oder
warum spielst du wirst verlieren
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde köpfe war
zusammen mit hallo klima.de zusammen mit
handlung hallo hallo hallo hallo jetzt
hier ist google youtube am stadion
flughafen statt
hallo körper freunde wie spieler sowie
wahlweise zwei ich werde werden dass
wenn ihr zwei runden spielen oder wenn
ein unentschieden spielen wenn auch eine
runde und da werde ich in drei tagen
oder so wenn wir noch mal eine runde
spielte haye und ich würde sagen wir
starten das spiel du weißt wie es geht
ich weiß wie es geht einfach irgendwie
gegen deine linien kommen oder ging
meine ja genau es gibt noch ein paar
items aber du wirst schon mit der zeit
erfahren was sie alles aussagen ich
verwechsle dir auch immer sonst wenn ich
jetzt sagen wir starten einfach das
spiel wäre das also ich werde auf jeden
fall fehlen wer weiss ehrlich du bist
bestimmter profi du meintest ja auch du
bist nicht eingespielt oder so ich bin
überhaupt nicht
ich weiß nicht warum der staat behält
das spiel neue frist gibt es viel zu
schwer fällt wenn wir zurück zu
reagieren hängt eigentlich nur
eingestellt oder beim spiel immerhin
freuen
ich zitiere kommen wir von 14 sekunden
du wirst verlieren aber ich liebe dieses
spiel ist so das kann immer so spielen
schreibt war die kommentare ob mehr
davon wollte was haben sie jetzt hier ja
dass ich mich auf trab
nix oder so jetzt knapp wieso bist du da
nicht gegen die dings gefahren
wahrscheinlich weil man damit vielleicht
durch die wände durchgehen da ja stimmt
ja ich nicht gedacht ja also ich werde
sehen wie das spiel der tisch fällt zwar
erwarte jetzt vergangenheit statt dick
machen
laser luca risso 2 1 alles klar zwei
alter wir werden jetzt machen wenn ich
jetzt zwei spiele gewinnen habe ich
gefahren
wenn ich allerdings 1 gewinnen und komme
1 dann ist auch ein drittes
entscheidungsspiel attacke für mich die
grünen sachen wenn die größe und sind
lieber auf sich bezogen wenn die rätsel
auf den gegner
ok richtig gespannt auf diese runden
ja ich war bei gott kann man kann auch
die pfeiltaste nach vorne drücken
bewirkt irgendwie dass man schneller
fährt oder kann man nix machen glaube
ich ok aber was haben jetzt eigentlich
verändern nach kollege nix oder
verändern begann wasser einfach einmal
die pfeiltasten dann nochmal ein
gedrückt sagt man also für das system
soll erkenntlich gemacht die waren ja
eigentlich schon eine richtig richtig
komische linien irgendwie sonst jemals
richtig einander etwas auseinander herum
und jetzt nochmal wie lange wir spielen
wer also selbst steht der gerade 32
man spielt bis 10 ist das erste spiel
vorbei wenn sagt die grünen teile die
sind immer gut wenn sagt mir ich jetzt
das spiel gewinnen also ich gewinne zum
beispiel 10 3 was ja sehr realistisch
ist das jetzt einfach sieben punkte
da habe ich halt das erste spiel
gewonnen wenn ich dann noch ein spiel
gewinne kommen zeichnet kreis
doch immer nur auf die yacht auch bleibt
es selbst gefallen gestellt wir haben
wohl eher wenn ich jetzt gewinne und das
nächste spiel gewinnen dann auch dann
ist diese aufnahme beendet aber wenn ich
jetzt gewinn und du die nächste dann
stand nach halt noch ein
entscheidungsspiel
du bist du es echt hart am limit alter
er hat richtig war das knapp ja bei mir
aber auch nein ich habe die dinge ich
hab mir die dinger verteilt
ach ja das ist echt das frechste mit den
umdrehen oder dass man weg wie das ist
auch das bemerkt man ja auch gar nicht
mehr denken ja ich drücke auch die
rechte taste rechts man muss man muss
immer auf den anderen auch achten
nein ach naja vielleicht schon manchmal
mehr so viel glück haben manchmal aber
du ja nicht bisher kacke ich drehe jetzt
mal eine extra honig ich war einfach mal
am rad entlang
das ist das dümmste was du machen kannst
sie hat mich fatal mit der steuerung
über andere richtung
hallo ich bekomme ich von außen dann
kann man das immer kurz glaube ich
dachte jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt ist jeder
an seiner seite
und da spielt das mit zum ersten mal
gerade hast du diese musik noch an
hier habe ich nicht so richtig schöne
pianomusik gerade die schildkröte ohne
das war nicht gut auch etwas blaues was
war anders blau ganz viele items glaube
ich komme einfach schlagregen geschafft
ist und jetzt habe ich einen dicken hals
ich hab echt deckenstrahler eben nicht
halt dein maul
so komme herr kollege ich drehe man
runden
erst war ich immer einen penis hat das
war so knapp nicht alle sekunden hinter
die auch gestorben
nein das ist matchball für dich
konzentrier dich dabei okay du hast als
linker nicht wie wunderschöner fehde ist
kann ich es darauf holen aber echt geil
ich hab das schwer soll zum ersten mal
so dass man echt spaß bis jetzt aber
noch einmal dran hängen ich muss das
jetzt gewinnen sonst das waren nur zwei
runden diese folge erkundigen
das war so wird das längste spiel was
man besser hatten linien kennt das nicht
mal gemeinsam etwas mal ein keine ahnung
mal eine reparatur muss gewinnen ach so
etablieren wird immer was aus unseren
zeichnungen interpretieren
das hast du gemacht hat das könnte ein
kind auf seinen schlitten sein
vielleicht stelle bekommt nach vorne ist
und gleich in schneeflächen als
eingeschlafen ich weiß eine mutter mit
dem kind im arm unser decker das ist das
war die coolste was ich für 31 ja komm
ich lass dir den vorsprung und jetzt was
können wir jetzt machen hier schönes
nein sich aus brenzligen was ist denn
das nix eigentlich das ist keine
rennstrecke sein
ich hab jetzt innerhalb von fünf
sekunden zu bashen 234 verdammt ist das
hier schnitten oder das ist ja das ist
eine leiche auf dem schlitten 33
was nimmst du wie es ausgeht ich schätze
x 10.7 und du für wen entscheiden sie
was ich war schon weiter und dann wo ich
aber eigentlich wieder zurückgeschnitten
für wen in 10 75 auch so natürlich
mische ich habe keine chat gewendet wir
malen jetzt einfach mal so items nein
auch kommt schon 53 wie denkst du wird
es ausgehen
10 3 10 3
ohne scheiß ich glaub was kriege ich
wenn ich's 10.3 ausgeht ein haufen
scheiße schicken wir wirklich laufen
stress gibt okay
bcg triathlon front ich gebe das adresse
einfach an die idee das stück scheiße
wer hätte gross vorgaben wo es wirklich
mit 10 3 werden wenn leute in siebter
punkte ich hole jetzt auch ich hole auf
ich konzentriere mich diese musik vor
allem
und ist auch wie eine lücke entsteht
denn ich will die chance einfach 83 aber
jetzt hast du scheiße getränke mich auf
einmal an
ja ich überholte wieder
dann bekommst du keine chance
wir haben gesagt wenn 10.3 ausgeht dann
ach so ja stimmt es dass jetzt schon den
vierten punkt glück gehabt und luca euro
gespart
nein es war wie dieses item sich die
toll dass hier die steuerung wir
vertrauen
ich liebe ja okay die rolle gilt als
wahrscheinlich da müssen wir noch eine
entscheidungsrunde dranhängen ok als ob
du gewinnst weil ich gereist ist um na
ja wohl aber das ist gut wenn man
solchen kunden einfach nicht gedrückt
hält sondern immer so ein bisschen tippt
aber die das ist total kaka macht lieber
nicht komme was nicht so und jetzt jetzt
eine ganz leichte kurve somit tipps oder
kann man echt schöne kurven fahren
alle hochkonzentriert aber bleibt der
strecke ab und da bringt auch tippen in
der kurve dich viel auf dem reichlich
den 96 auf chat du wirst verlieren sage
ich dir auch prof
wie schaffst du dann mal wieder da raus
zu kommen
ich glaube das spiel war in weißrussland
1 angehoben
ich war einfach um das alte proben es
kann doch nicht wahr sein doch leider
muss so eine kacke
heute wird luca das team verliert da ist
aber eng wie straff beschuldigt ihr
machen müsst
mein gott okay wir raten ja auch gar
nicht mehr was ich hab seit sieben
punkten habe ich schon verdammt
matchball
das kann ich seit ich bin vom 9 3 auf 9
9 abgerutscht meine lieben freunde hat
kann ich sein
jetzt hat er jetzt verlängerung bis 11
glaube ich sogar junge aber ich glaube
es ist ich glaube es geht jetzt bis 11
oder ein traum
ja es gibt es elf jetzt ja okay kommt ja
ich muss gehören tie-break netz des
jetzt gibt es auch noch bei einem
notfall 12 ja wenn jetzt einsehen dass
am 12
okay zwei punkte vorsprung wir haben
aber recht kann aber dafür brauche ich
nicht so viel brauche ich nicht da bin
ich schon früher und müssten schnell
wenn es macht ist überlegen hat er ihr
ausgespielten elf zu null war das hier
nahezu aber ich begründe diese spannende
wir brauchen noch eine entscheidung
freunde
los geht's okay so
nein weil ich die darauf achtet wie
wichtig es aus also das ist ein grüner
blitz der ok welche durch ein grüner
blitz komme nein nein verdammt wo doch
so 111 rugby spiele und geschichten
plötzlich wetter 14 1 gewinnen
okay und ich möchte auf jeden fall mit
wenn ich das spiele 10.1 gewinne dann
fahre ich jetzt gleich zum spielplatz
und rutschen rutsche runter
ich spüre ich wie heute ich spiele nicht
mehr ich mach einfach keine mittel tanzt
du musst nicht anstrengen wie ich gesagt
jetzt wenn dann wenn das ganze spiel 10
10 11 zu 9 ausgeht dann mache ich das
dann richtig in rage runter wo verdammt
und du gewinnst du musst eine schnelle
wirst du ja das ist die schnellste bus
der welt danke cagliari trainiert in
oxford
in oxford
besser dass der blitz comedy musste
einsammeln und ich nehme schon die haben
wir von der tastatur oder alle ist ja du
kommst einfach andere kann man bremsen
wer als mehr gefahr sie dort einfach
bremst einfach stehen bleiben kostet
dich aber du okay wir machen das ding so
was macht das teil wieder entspannung
pur meine damen und herren
synchronsprecher einfach synchronisation
ein bild des wagens war an der wand
grüner blitz
das war doch etwas rotes nein das war
ein grüner blitz oder wird das bei mir
als rot angezeigt ja aber wenn dir das
auch als grün angezeigt durch mein vater
ich schwöre es mit grüner blitz
es ist ein grüner blitz komme wirklich
mittelfeld zeigen gesammelt ja ja du
möchtest noch nicht ersichtlich speed
boost bekommen
ja du bist doch vorbild mich
reingefahren
ich wette du ich hab sind titel so bombe
getroffen
nein das habe ich habe als kreatives
einfallen schreibt komme hat eine lange
wurst
ich liebe in form von anfang als
italiens und cooles komplizierter wieder
um eine runde auf einer koppel fehlt
einfach und ich heute so eine explosion
getötet 75 mit unseren zehn neuen
connect werden
mit knapp 85 gewinne ich dieses erste
spiel
sogar fast alle blitze eingesammelt die
du gesagt hast du warst du ich auf dem
spielfeld und das fahrzeug
du musst im spiel verbleiben ich im auto
schiff herausfahren was heißt das denn
jetzt so dass man durch die wände kann
die ja auch wer durch bachelor komplett
durch meine dame heftig ich hole auch so
was macht das da oben eigentlich scheiße
ich habe gewonnen
ich habe gewonnen mann ich bin der
glorreiche sieger die lehre muss sein
ich bin der glorreiche siege gegen hd in
marl auf jeden fall dankeschön
in ein paar tagen wird noch eine folge
kommen
erstmal muss das nicht danke ein paar
tagen kommentieren da das erstmals die
idee ein paar tagen kommt noch mal der
runde ging komme hd mal schauen wie es
dann weiter entwickelt mir erstaunlich
gewinnen wird gegen den profi gegen den
habe ich auch schon gewonnen und ich
habe kein geld ich habe ihr freund kay
heruntergeladen und hab dann eine idee
story runtergeladen und hat dann immer
so ab und zu gesehen so alles
funktioniert jedoch nicht glaub ich
gesagt es gab immer so geist ich hab
immer so geistererscheinungen und bombe
fand das irgendwie voll wird sich als
ich das gesagt ich würde sagen ich wenn
ihr euch gefällt aber auch auf jeden
fall die finden es auch voll geil ist
wirklich gepostet
freude wenn es euch gefallen hat lassen
bewertung darüber wir sehen uns dann in
den nächste video wieder was ihr euch
anschauen kommen steht in der
beschreibung und ciao ciao